[Musique]
c'est jour de rentrée à miguil les
étudiants font la queue pour goûter les
produits alimentaires offerts à leurs
cafétérias
ces melons viennent de la ferme et
danone le quément peu ça gros
alimentaires de l'université mcgill à 45
minutes du centre-ville
ils sont notre plus grand fournisseur de
soins et légumes pendant ou ce plan
moteur
les vols de volpi du service alimentaire
de l'université est très fier de voir
que mig il offre des produits locaux
dans ces 25 comptoir alimentaire
on est vraiment maintenant 50% mais on a
l'objectif de lui rende non à un
disposant de plus dans lesquels prochain
quelques années et sans la ferme de
l'université ce serait beau si notre
raison d'être c'est ferrer a cherché
dans ses mains mais en même temps nous
sommes d'une ferme normal on produit des
des fruits et légumes ont produit du
lait des oeufs
je pense qu'on est un petit peu chanceux
qu'eux
monsieur mais dans notre camp qui a
parti collège ici il ya mis en place des
fermes sur le campus mais on a toujours
eu un petit entrepôt ici où on vendait
un petit marché mc marque dont la belle
où on va des seuls plus de la sphère ont
vendu ces produits là nos étudiants nos
professeurs et un petit peu la
communauté à l'entrée de cette abondance
de fruits et légumes
un projet a germé mais qu'il nourrit
miguil c'est un projet avec mon collègue
en ville de bagdad ainsi d'améliorer la
nourriture à melwood alors il voulait
commencer avec une production locale
quand que su qu'on avait un capes dédiée
à la production de ce végétal
on s'est mis ensemble et on a trouvé une
manière de essayer de le fournir
[Musique]
depuis près de 10 ans mais cafétéria de
l'université sont devenus des clients
gourmands
ça demande une immense quantité de
produits la production un seul jour aux
alentours de 25 mille kg de nourriture
qu'on lui fournit dalle moment et c'est
local
ces frais récoltés on reçoit la
canebière on livre ou aujourd'hui ici
s'il peut pas avoir mieux que ça
une augmentation de la demande exige des
adaptations sauf à ce que tous les yeux
qui n'utilisent aucun quotidien ta nea
passé nous avons pour nous sont à peu
près 13002 n12 pour café thé la prothèse
et 80 à manger tout qu'est-ce qui la
question des oeufs
ça avait l'air facile il fallait qu'ils
nous certifie fédéralement pour être
capable à utiliser les autres qu'on
produisait d'aller gratter à lutter
c'est ont toujours été là la machine à
me fallait ajouter de la machinerie
engagés du monde et c'est tout
après tout des étudiants qui veulent
travailler les femmes et sais pas je
suis étudiant en agronomie
ils veulent tout travaillé dans un bar à
salades on a plusieurs produits qui
viendra alors tout seul vous exactement
les tomates des courges aujourd'hui on
offrait les courges qui sont rôties
notre ferme à
hockey du québec qui amènerait à ses
justes parmi un des choix qu'on avait
sur le menu aujourd'hui qui causent les
fermer par québécois c'est comme ça tous
les jours à tous les jours il ya des
options comme ça c'est sûr on a
tellement de produits qui rentrent ici
hanegev on achète pour à peu près 7
millions par année et la ferme des
présents sinon 130 mille dollars quelque
chose alors on a besoin on a du travail
à faire dans les autres catégories aussi
mais cafétéria de l'université mcgill
servent quotidiennement 10 à 12 mai un
repas pour y arriver on fait appel à
d'autres fournisseurs
on travaille avec brio pour le pain au
travail avec du breton pour le port on
travaille boeuf québec
axel d'or pour le poulet je pourrais
contient continue
en plus de consolider sa position de
chef de file l'université peut aussi
mettre l'accent sur les pratiques
éthiques et la certification équitable
mais tout cela coûte cher les étudiants
sont ils d'accord avec les prix
pour certaines choses
pour des gros porcs qui sont à part ces
légumes oui qualité mais pour d'autres
choses comme une barre tendre avec 10
collation un peu moins comme les cta
mais beaucoup de capitales je pense que
c'est le seul café qui vendent dans les
quêtes montre que cette cafétéria ch'ti
et puis ça motive beaucoup les gens à
acheter
kayalar repas chauds 6 9 45 le rapport
végétarien célébrités 45
et puis dit aussi des vols d'appareils
qui sont de ses 25
est ce que c'est bon la question la plus
importante c'est chaud mais au moins
c'est bon souvent les gens disent on
veut bien manger local mais ça coûte
plus cher que je dirais pas qu'on va
augmenter mais ont choisi prudemment les
produits qu'on va utiliser des produits
de la ferme qu'on reçoit sont vraiment
le prix du marché
cette offre locale explique t'elle
automatiquement la malbouffe des
cafétérias
pas du tout on a d un beau gris si on
transfère beaucoup il est un bonheur ils
sont veufs québec on a des droits de
poulets mais ça vient des eaux -
d'exceldor alors on sait d'où vient ces
produits ont choisi au moins un mérite
sion pour qu'est ce qui est à l'achat
local pour supporter des fermiers qui
sont des producteurs québécois
on est vraiment des leaders à travers du
canada on est fier de ça mais on espère
que les autres universités vont me
copier comme toi on va les copier leur
belle initiative
j'aimerais ça qu'on grandisse mais ça
prend demain les étudiants sont là où il
ya peut-être quarantaine d'étudiants
qu'on engage en saison pour faire ses
des colts là mais les étudiants leur
premier job c'est c'est leur éducation
[Musique]